Let's develop your intuition
a little bit more.
We'll use this hypothetical dag.
Now suppose the dag has work W(n) and
span D(n).
The ratio of work to span or w divided
by d has a special interpretation.
It basically measures the amount
of work per critical path vertex.
So, think about that for a second.
At every critical path vertex,
there's an average amount of work.
So this ratio basically tells you
the average available parallelism
in the dag.
So imagine you're a critical
path vertex like this one.
When that critical path vertex executes,
there's going to be a bunch of work
sitting around and on average, the
amount of such work is W divided by D.
So what does that imply?
Suppose I give you a PRAM
with P processors.
How many processors should you use?
It looks like it would be nice to
have about w over d processors.
And if that's the case you can basically
keep the processors busy on average.
Work and
span give us some more information.
You know for example that the span is
a lower bound on the execution time.
We are going to give
this a special name,
we are going to call it the Span Law,
punishable by death.
Now that's a lowerbound in terms of the
span but it's not the only lowerbound.
Another scenario I could imagine
is taking all of the work, and
if there is no critical path,
then I would just divide that work
evenly among the p processors.
And that would give me
another lower bound.
Basically the ceiling of W divided P.
And we'll give than
an ominous name as well.
The work law.
Now I have a pea-sized brain.
I don't like remembering all these laws,
so
I'm going to write this more compactly.
Both laws hold, so I can combine them.
Basically the two laws have to be true
simultaneously so I can combine them.
So remember, W/D tells you the average
available parallelism, and W and D
together given P gives you a lower bound
which is this combined work span law.
Commit these to memory.